todo esto está muy bien pero tenemos un
problema les comenté que estas dos
ranuras están muy cercanas entre sí
quizás a una distancia de micro metros o
incluso nanómetros como podremos medir
físicamente la diferencia entre las
longitudes de las rutas si veo la
barrera me parecerá que estos dos puntos
están en la misma posición así de
cercanos están por lo que necesito una
forma de encontrar la diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta con base en algo que
yo sí pueda medir y aquí vamos a hacer
un truco vamos a encontrar una función
para encontrar esta diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta con base en el
ángulo que tengo la idea básica es esta
permítanme quitar todo esto y vamos a
explicarlo de esta manera digamos que
voy a dibujar una línea de referencia la
línea de referencia va a pasar
exactamente por el centro esta línea
central es mi amiga ya que me va a
permitir medir ángulos tengo esta línea
aquí y digamos que quiero medir un
ángulo es la para
qué ángulo va a ser voy a medir voy a
medir este ángulo así voy a tener una
línea que va de aquí del centro hasta un
punto en la pared
digamos que acá esto de aquí va a ser mi
ángulo y la pregunta aquí es con base en
este ángulo habrá una forma de encontrar
la diferencia en la longitud de la ruta
esto es lo importante como determinó
esta diferencia como está relacionada a
la diferencia de la longitud de la ruta
con este ángulo la forma en que podemos
hacerlo es esta si esta pantalla está
muy lejana voy a dibujar una línea desde
el centro de la ranura de abajo hasta
este punto y voy a dibujar una línea
desde el centro de la ranura de arriba
hacia este mismo punto y si esta
pantalla está lejos más lejana comparada
con la distancia entre estas dos ranuras
lo cual no será un problema ya que estas
dos ranuras están prácticamente una
junto a otra ahora podría dibujar una
tercera línea y esta tercera línea se ve
así
de aquí hasta tocar a esta otra línea
con un ángulo recto y ya que mi pantalla
está lejana se va a cumplir que si esto
es un ángulo recto lo que queda de estas
rutas me dirá lo mismo la ruta de aquí
hacia acá tendrá la misma longitud que
la ruta desde este punto hacia acá por
lo que la diferencia en las longitudes
de las rutas va a ser esto de acá lo que
sea que sobre y esto es delta x como
encuentro esto bueno si esto está lejos
este ángulo de acá va aa ser igual al
ángulo que se encuentra aquí estos dos
ángulos son iguales y ahora que sé que
estos dos ángulos son iguales usaré la
trigonometría básica ya que tengo aquí
un triángulo rectángulo voy a redibujar
lo por acá mi triángulo rectángulo se ve
así tengo esta distancia entre las
ranuras
esta es la distancia entre las ranuras
la distancia de centro al centro ahora
voy a dibujar esta línea naranja que
tuve que dibujar para formar un ángulo
de 90 grados y finalmente tengo la
diferencia en las longitudes de la ruta
ese es mi triángulo que es un triángulo
rectángulo y esta es mi delta x la
diferencia en la longitud de las rutas
la cantidad extra que esta onda tuvo que
viajar al salir aquí abajo al menos
comparada con la distancia que tuvo que
viajar a partir de la ranura de arriba
esto se resuelve con trigonometría aquí
tengo mi ángulo recto tiene una relación
entre estas y vamos a decir que el seno
de theta que teta es esta la cual es la
misma que la teta de acá el seno de teta
va a ser igual al lado opuesto entre la
hipotenusa aquí el lado opuesto es mi
delta x tengo delta x entre la
hipotenusa la hipotenusa de este
triángulo es esta vez la distancia entre
las dos ranuras ya que está opuesto al
ángulo recto
y la hipotenusa jamás va a tocar al
ángulo recto así que esto es entre de
cuál va a ser la diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta va a ser b por seno
de teta y esto es lo que quiero ahora sé
que delta x es igual a d por el seno de
teta y ahora puedo escribir la fórmula
de la doble ranura vamos a quitar esto y
la fórmula luce así m por lambda es
igual a d por el seno de teta y
recordemos que deja x para los puntos
constructivos es un múltiplo de la
longitud de onda cero una longitud de
onda dos longitudes de onda etcétera así
que para poder tener puntos
constructivos de por el seno de theta
que es la diferencia en la longitud de
la ruta tiene que ser 0 holanda o 2
lambda etcétera esta es la fórmula de la
doble ranura está m va a ser cero o uno
o dos etcétera d es la distancia entre
las ranuras esto es d
theta es el ángulo que se forma desde la
línea central hasta el punto en la pared
en donde tenemos nuestro punto
constructivo y lambda es la longitud de
onda la distancia entre los picos de la
onda y en teoría podríamos usar mitades
nm para encontrar los ángulos de los
puntos destructivos ya que sabemos que
delta x la diferencia entre la longitud
de la ruta tiene que ser igual a la
mitad del hambre para ser destructiva
así que esta misma fórmula nos puede dar
los ángulos tanto para los puntos
constructivos como para los puntos
destructivos si es que ponemos los
valores correctos nm a estos valores
también se les llama orden el orden de
los puntos constructivos ese sería el
orden cero ya que la diferencia entre
las longitudes de la ruta es cero
algunas veces a esto se le llama el
primer orden porque tiene una longitud
de onda de diferencia esta podría ser la
de segundo orden ya que tiene dos
longitudes de onda de diferencia y
ustedes podrían quejarse
oye esto no es mejor ya que ve es muy
pequeña esto es muy cercano y esto es
tan cercano que no podemos medirlo es
cierto pero si podemos medir theta y
conocemos la longitud de onda del láser
que estamos usando por lo que podemos
contar en qué orden nos encontramos esta
es una forma rápida de calcular que si
tenemos algo con dos ranuras en él
podremos encontrar la distancia que los
separa aún cuando no tengamos una regla
tan pequeña como para medirlo le
dirigimos una luz tendremos un patrón de
difracción como éste un patrón de
interferencia medimos el ángulo y ahora
puede encontrar la distancia entre estas
dos ranuras y podemos hacer muchos
experimentos para determinar con
precisión qué tan cercanos se encuentran
estos dos agujeros en alguna cuña de
cristal o estructura molecular y se va a
determinar por la ecuación de la doble
ranura de jong